if you imagine Spider-Man Marvel's super
agile superhero slinging a variety of
deadly magic spells rather than webs you
have a pretty good idea of what it's
like to play for spoken Square enix's
upcoming open world action game puts
equal emphasis on quick movement and
bombarding your opponents with all
manner of magic in an experience that's
all about fast thinking smart movement
and overwhelming Force Square Enix
recently gave Gamespot a chance to play
about an hour of forespoken in a curated
demo we didn't play the actual game but
rather a specifically crafted slice that
demonstrated how forspoken will feel and
give a sense of how its open world will
work in some ways what we saw forespoken
felt familiar for anyone who's played a
lot of open world games there are a lot
of locations to unlock small challenges
to complete and items to collect to
upgrade protagonist phrase powers
where for spoken stands apart is in its
traversal and combat once you get the
hang of both
fast and frenetic game giving you a
whole host of abilities to use against
enemies while you have to think about
how best to use all the magic weapons at
your disposal the fun of forespoken is
in the speed it relies Less on
methodical planning and more on hitting
opponents with everything you've got the
demo we played took place in a series of
vast Fields craggy valleys and swampy
lowlands most of the time you'll be
getting around with forespoken's magical
parkour system which has been a big
highlight of trailers and gameplay
videos so far holding down a single face
button on your controller activates the
ability which causes Frey to bound
forward and to automatically climb up or
spring off any obstacles that get in our
way you can't parkour forever though
Frey has a limited amount of stamina
that has to be recharged after a while
to get the most out of the traversal
system you want to plan your moves
through the world to actually hit
obstacles to use them to your advantage
for instance just bounding across an
open field will let you move last for a
short period but you'll get farther if
you cut through a stand of trees because
Frey will kick off them as she passes to
get extra speed and distance you'll also
want to combine the parkour system with
Frey's ability to grab onto Ledges and
special rocks with a sort of magical
rope which allows her to zip forward or
upward like Spidey making his way up a
building or across rooftops getting
around in four spoken feels pretty good
and the game keeps things pretty simple
so that you don't have to do much more
than hold down a button and steer for
free to navigate terrain but even the
demo we saw had a pretty huge open world
with a lot of space between points of
interest a fast travel system you unlock
by visiting key locations helps make
moving around quicker and easier it
seems that while parkouring around the
map will be a main focus of the
experience the parkour mechanics are
better for shorter trips around objects
at least until you unlock more
capabilities as you explore and fray
levels up I found myself running out of
steam as I tried to cross large areas
and it took me a while to get a sense of
how to utilize the system to make
getting around fun instead of arduous
parkour is also a big part of for
spoken's approach to combat which is all
about keeping on the move and walloping
enemies with a huge amount of magic
spells developers at luminous
Productions say players will eventually
have access to 100 spells or more we saw
a handful of these in our demo and they
were divided into categories you've got
purple magic spells that sound like
they're intrinsic to fray with themes of
being Earth and plant-based and red
magic spells that Drew their power from
fire under each color you've got two
main spell types attack spells are your
main way of inflicting damage and allow
you to cast them over and over like a
charged up ball of Earth or a rocky
Shield that could block damage and then
crash forward in a hail of stones the
second main type is support spells which
had different effects like binding a
group of enemies to a spot or calling up
a projectile launching flower to act as
a turret support spells all have
cooldown timers but you have access to a
lot of them and can quickly change them
on a weapon wheel allowing you to cast
several in succession as you pair them
with your attack spells the trick in
forespoken is to use all those spells
together in smart ways some enemies are
weak against a specific color of magic
like purple or red others are best
handled with a specific support spell
flying enemies for instance are tough to
hit with spells that stick to the ground
all the while during combat you're using
parkour to keep yourself moving dodging
coming attacks and earn bonuses by using
spells as you're flipping through the
air it gets a bit hectic which is where
for spoken benefits from a pretty
standard lock-on system I found that
trying to aim spells manually was a
tough proposition in most fights thanks
to how quickly everything tends to move
once I got the hang of the combat system
it quickly became my favorite part of
forespoken and the mix of tactical
Thinking Fast and agile movement and
all-out magical superiority makes for an
interesting mix for an action game
foreign though combat and parkour felt
great and forespoken other elements were
tougher to get a beat on small
challenges seem likely to be scattered
all around for spoken's World of athia
keeping you busy for short bursts of
time many of the elements we saw seemed
pretty standard for open World Games
things like visiting a point of interest
to unlock a fast travel destination or
fighting a group of monsters guarding a
treasure chest or completing timed
combat challenges the boss fights were
great but even though the activities in
the demo were fine none of them felt
like standout additions to open world
games that are going to make players sit
up and take notice of these kinds of
small map filling jobs the other thing
that we only got a small sample of was
the relationship between Frey and the
cuff the magical talking bracelet that
provides her with different abilities
and also acts as her traveling companion
the relationship between Frey and her
Enchanted jewelry seems like it's going
to be a central focus in first spoken
and as such you're going to hear a lot
of banter between them this is the place
on Joe heady's map
are you planning on retrieving her
smithing gear might as well while we're
here hearing Frey and cuff discuss the
world which seems foreign to both of
them helps make even traveling across
Open Fields seem like it's providing
something important to the game and
gives the characters a lot more life
combat banter on the other hand could
Veer toward the grading although I
didn't get a complete sense of what it
might be like in the full game for
spoken's brand of humor has been the
source of some derision thanks to a
recent story trailer and while my demo
didn't include any story points the
dialogue wasn't keeping with that style
mostly the issue is that I heard a lot
of the same gags admonishments and
complaints during my short time with the
game here's hoping that first spoken has
more variety in these areas when it
releases since listening to Frey and
cough talk or fight or complement each
other seems like a very big part of the
overall experience where are you right
here at the end of your own the slice up
for spoken I saw didn't convey too much
about the overall game narrative and
storytelling are a big part of the game
and none of that was in the demo for
example but the hour I played provided a
sense of the fast-paced magical action
at the game's heart it takes a few
minutes to get a feel for it but once
you understand what for spoken is going
for its traversal and combat systems
start to feel really great
the idea of slinging a hundred spells
against enemies while jumping climbing
and flipping to keep out of Harm's Way
is an enticing one and for spoken
systems seem like they'll be as fun to
use as they've been to watch and
trailers when the game releases in
January on PlayStation 5 and PC